ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في مصر جدل واسع
بعد الاعلان عن عمل فني وجسد حياه راحل
محمد متولي الشعراوي جعلت الازهر ينتفض
للرد والبرلمان يتحرك للمساءله البدايه
كانت مع تردد الاعلام بان هناك عملا فنيا
لاعاده صياغه صيغه الشعراوي دراميه
لتقديمها على المسرح القومي حمله الهجوم
على الشعراوي بدات مع الكاتبه والنائف
البرلمان المصري فريده شوبشي التي تقدمت
بطلب احاطه لوزيره الثقافه بين الكيلاني
حول الموضوع ويتساءل تشوب شيء كيف يقوم
المسرح القومي وزاره الثقافات بانتاج
مسرحيه عن الشيخ الشعراوي الذي سجد لله
شكرا على هزيمه 67 وقال بثقه انه فرحه
لهزيمه مصر اما النقد مجد خير الله فكشفت
عن رايها في تقديم سيره الشيخ الشعراوي
على المسرح القومي
الى تن في ناس اكثر اهميه بكثير من هو
قدموا للمجتمع اشياء مفيده الازهر بدوره
رد على الحمله والانتقادات واكد بان الشيخ
الشعراوي مثال للعالم الوسطيه المستنير
ولديه مواقف وطنيه مشرفه
وجهود موافقه في رد الشبهات عن الاسلام
اول القران
ومتابعه وانطلاقه في الواقع من هذا الجدل
مطرح مجموعه من الاسئله على ضيوفنا من
القاهره الشيخ عبد العزيز النجار وكيل
وزاره سابق بالاثار اهلا بك من القاهره
طارق شناوي الناقد الفني اهلا بكمين واسمح
لي ان ابدا معك يا شيخ عبد العزيز الشيخ
عبد العزيز في الواقع همم ما يهمنا في كل
هذا الجدل ليست تفاصيل او مقيد عن الشيخ
الشعراوي رحمه الله ولكن الموضوع المطروح
هو هل علماء الدين همم لا يمكن طرحهم
للنقد اليس شخصيه عامه يمكن نقدها لان
البعض لما طرح جدل الشيخ الشعراوي
من هذه الانتقادات واعتبروا بان هناك
وكانه مساسا بالمقدسات ما راي حضرتك في
الموضوع
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
بدايه ليس هناك
شخص فوق النقد وليست هناك قداسه لبشر ابدا
الا المعصوم وهو الانبياء جميعا المعصومين
وهم الانبياء جميعا فكل انسان كما قال
الامام مالك يؤخذ من قوله ويطرق الا صاحب
هذا القبر واشار الى قبر النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم اما بالنسبه لان علماء
الدين شخصيات عامه هم ليسوا شخصيات عامه
وانما هم شخصيات
تحملت مسؤوليه الدعوه والدين الاسلامي
فعندما يتم نقض هؤلاء اما انني انقض الشخص
في تصرفاته الشخصيه وسلوكه وهذا مباح
للجميع واما انني انتقده في بعض
وهذا يقول للمتخصصين في هذا المجال وليس
لغيرهم واقف ثالثا اذا اختلفنا مع اي عام
هذا الموضوع لما تقول بانه همم عادي ان
ينتقدوا في سلوكهم في شخصيههم ولكن ان لا
ينتقد في اقوالها لهم باختصار ما الذي
تعنيه
قد يكون مثلا انا عبد العزيز النجار رجل
دين ربما همم البعض لا يعجبه سلوكيات خاصه
به اما بما يخص اقوال العلميه اللي هو
نتائج همم علم خاص
به الشيخ الشعراوي وهو تفسير القران
الكريم وتعرضه لبعض الايات التي تحتاج الى
فتوى الى احكام فقهيه فهنا يبقى نحن نختلف
معه في قضيه فقهيه يبقى قضيه علميه يبقى
النقاش فيها يكون نقاش علمي ويحق لاي
انسان عنده من العلم ان يدلب دون ان يجرح
في الشخصيه او دون
نعم نعم
يقول بان بانتقاد الاقوال سيقتصر على رجال
العلم العلم مقابل العلم لا يحق لمواطن
عادي ان ينتقد اقوال او تصرفاته هنا ربما
الكلام ل اا من انتقدوا شيخ شعراوي همم في
اقواله في سلوكه في افعاله في بعض من همم
هذه التصريحات التي قدمها ما رايك
بالعكس انا شايف انه لو انتقدنا الشخص
يعني بيسهر بالليل همم بياكل كذا ما
بياكلش كذا صوروه مثلا وهو ماشي في حته او
مثلا بيصيف همم ولابس مايوه زي اي احد في
الدنيا هو ده التصرف
السيء لان انا كنت هنا هنا الشخص لكن
القول هو الذي يتم همم الحديث عنه وتناوله
في فرق بين مساله فقهيه وبين مساله عامه
بمعنى انه مثلا لما همم شيخ الشعراوي وهو
قطعا حاله خاصه جدا واستثنائيه بين كل
الدعاء عبر كل الزمالك حقيقي وله كاريزما
وله حضور ولها جمهور ومؤثر حتى الان صوره
موجوده في مصر همم
وفي العالم العربي انا مثلا لما همم اسمع
واقرا واشوف مش بس كده والحديث موثق انه
هو صلى ركعتين شكر لربنا ان احنا اتهزمنا
في 67
وكان وكان يعني تفسيره او يعني بيوضح ده
انه كان مصر كانت زمان اللي هو ايام
اتحسوا فيتي كانت مصر بتتوجه الى القوه
العظمى اللي هي الشرقيه اللي هي روسيا
حاليا يعني هي تحاسبتي فقال لك ودول
شيعيين فبالتالي يتبسط ازاي حاجه زي كده
لازم تجرحني
كانسان واوقع عربي حتى انك انت بلدك بياخذ
25% على الاقل من ارضه تاخذها اسرائيل
وابنك وابوك
وابن عمتك وجارك بيستشهدوا وواحد مع كل
احترام له بيصلي ركعتين بيشكر ربنا هنا
ليست بس انا فقيه لا دي مساله شخصيه لما
مثلا الشيخ متولي الشعراوي مع كل الكلام
ده
استاذ استاذ طارق
الدين في السياسه كذلك الحرب هي في اطار
عسكري وانما الدين سيبقى منفصلا فلماذا
يتحدث هو الان رحمه الله هو في دار الحق
في دار الباطل ولكن همم هذه الانتقادات
تضع جدلا حول انتقاد همم رجال علوم الدين
نحن لم يعني انا شخصيا واغلب اللي انا
قراته لمن كتب لم نتعرض لامور فقهيه تماما
ده امر ليس فقه ليس فقه على الاطلاق ده لا
ده ده امر انساني لما مثلا همم الشيخ
متولي الشعراوي في حديث له بيتكلم عن عن
حديث الذبابه وازاي انك انت لو وقع
الذبابه همم بجناحها الايمن همم ما ترميش
الاكل لا حط جناحها الايسر في في احد
الجناحين ده وفي الاخر ده وقت لا لازم انا
اقول لا ده ضد المنطق ضد مهما قال لي ان
ده حديث هاقول له لا اكيد ده ليس حديث
موثوق به لانه ضد المنطق ضد ضد
حقيقه انا عايز بس اقول باختصار همم
بيصب في الافكار اوكي
شيخ عبد العزيز
نعم اولا دعيني اقول بالنسبه
لسجود الشيخ فهو وضح ذلك وهو الذي قال لم
يراه احد هو الذي قال في الاعلام انني
سجدت لانه كان ضد الفكر الشيوعي الذي كان
يسود في مصر
وقتا طويل وتفاصيل عزيزه
الذبابه حضرتك هو حديث صحيح في البخاري
ومسلم فقط
ما هي على مواضيع عامه على مواضيع انعام
يعني حضرتك حديث الذبابه ده موضوع عام ولا
موضوع فقهي وموجود في كتب السنه في
البخاري وموجود في مسلم فعندما نطعن فينا
نطعن في الشيخ الشعراوي وانما نطعم في كتب
السنه وهذا سيجال بين العلماء الشيخ
الغزالي تحدث في هذا الامر وهناك كثير من
العلماء بين مؤيد وبين معارض وهذا مجال
همم بين علماء الحديث وفي هناك ابحاث
كثيره وهناك اثراء لهذا الحديث وغيره من
الاحاديث التي اتخذوها البعض واعتبروها
انها شبهه وان طعن في السنه النبويه
الشريفه وهذا حديث من ضمن هذه الاحاديث
فهذا ليس قضيه عامه هذه قضيه دينيه تحته
ثابته بالسنه الصحيحه
استاذ طارق
بدون امثال حتى لا ندخل في الخيمه
والازهر الشريف بالمناسبه الازهر حرم
الختام مؤخرا طلع بيان من الازهر الشريف
وايضا الدوله المصريه جرمت مش بقى جرمت
الختان يعني الطبيب الذي يجري عمليه ختان
للمراه للمراه بيعاقب بالسجن الشيخ
الشعراوي قال لك ده اسمه خفاظ بس في
النهايه تعبير انما هو ختان يعني في اله
حاده
بتدخل على انسان وتقتطع جزء منه الشيخ
الشعراوي مع ده وده ضد برده وتوجه الدوله
يعني انا عايز اقول الدوله الدوله نفسه ضد
ده فبالتالي برده دي قضيه عامه وليست قضيه
همم الاعضاء التبرع بالاعضاء الشيخ الازهر
قائل في اكثر من حديث ان ده انت لا تملك
اعضاءك وبالتالي لا تتبرع بها والدوله مع
التبرع بالاعضاء انقاذ البشريه لما انا
اتكلم عن ده هنا مش باتكلم قضيه في خير لا
قضيه انسانيه انه شايف ان ده ضد العلم ضد
الانسان
العادي الغير مطلع على كل هذه التفاصيل ان
ينتقد او حتى لا نقول مواطن العادي على
المثقف الصحفي الناقد الفني ان ينتقل هذه
العباره همم
لما مثلا واحد بيعمل غسيل كلوي كويس فكل
لك انسان بتحبيه او انت او انا بنعمل غسيل
كله يقول مثلا انت ليه بتاخر على همم
حضرتك ثواني
اولا اولا اولا بالنسبه لقضيه الختان
الازهر نفسه اكثر من 1400 سنه يحرم الكتاب
اشكرك جزيل الشكر الشيخ عبد العزيز النجار
وكيل وزاره سابق بالازهر ومن القاهره كذلك
طارق الشناوي انا قد الفني اعتذر على ضيق
الوقت السلام عليكم